[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classic welcome to the round 7
recap for the fall chess classic today
there were only two decisive games
across both fields not a lot has changed
in the standings world woman's chest
Challenger June June defeated Alex Aman
off with the black pieces in a crucial
game for her standing in the tournament
and then in Group B angel Arriba's
defeated Tata of Abraham Ian with white
would this be a happy birthday for
shabal off sort of he had the black
pieces against Akshay Chandra the fields
combined have a prize fund of $36,000
the top prize in Group A is six grand
the top prize in Group B is four grand
the eighth and penultimate round is
Wednesday September 13 at 1 p.m. in st.
Louis the final round of regulation is
on Thursday at an early start time of 11
a.m. Central it was all draws today in
Group A except for one game a very
important game a very important win as
black for Jew when John thank you for
joining me and what a great win today /
Alexandra Shimano kind of keeps you in
contention what do you think your
chances are for finishing for finishing
this group oh well actually I'm
currently plus one now in the tomorrow I
will play the raffle and I think well
it's a if I win the game and I might
have chances to
you know trying for the you know the
first place and that's who knows so now
I think I'm some sort I'd 4/3 okay and
roofing I mean he's not having the most
impressive of tournaments and in the
last round and is against the arrows
Arabic who actually is in one of those
top spots so granted that last game is
with black for you but exciting stuff
not too far out let's take a look at the
game with Shimano of that you just had
his black I think now it's just a very
unclear precision and I was I think c5
is a decisive mistake for for him I mean
I think maybe he should try g4 and I was
thinking look I'm sorry this one it's on
and take this one if takes takes and the
white point is also very fast and looks
like my point is very difficult to to
keep moving and somehow I think and I
always think in this move but while he
is a very strong move like Bishop g7 go
take take and certainly the points or
it's wrong and I don't think I can hold
or stop them too
so I think this is what he should play
and and it will leads to very
complicated position and I was running
out of time so it will give me a very
big pressure
so after c5 I think my position is just
fine here and here is very interesting I
was thinking 97 but somehow I don't like
my position after this one neck 94 like
96 is 3 but there's very interesting
tactics here f5 and go takes takes takes
text and I think like Sweeney here and
but ok looking for is also good because
now black is playing without any risks
and the more there there is a past pole
and my black diamond out the shop is
very good and I was thinking in this
position maybe black is a white his
quite can hold I mean it's not like
losing game for white but during the
game I didn't find anything for him
and I think now mat night before is a
good move except if I play a 5 and maybe
he can play bishops history or even real
careful
I think after training the shop or
training the rook hand my point is not
so threatening so so I played night
before
and my idea is to make his King like go
back to the center and not to keep away
always telephone so taste this and I
think my position is just very good
hearing I think actually I think I have
a very good chance of seeing here and
now it's after 40 move and I was in I
think he was very very hard to defend
and this is a very ostentatious best
defense to stop me playing f3 and
actually this just to take the pawn
and here is very interesting
IKEA FICO ace if I go here I cook see
494 and the shop piece at the shops if I
it's very interesting at first I was
calculating this one but if God takes oh
no sorry Kim D Phi
yeah and if go takes a - I'm winning and
this one I think it's winning for plaque
and so but this is very interesting
like I couldn't pee - and if I moved my
Knights then just take a three point if
I play this one and Bishop g7 and
donkeys the shop is protected a one
square and I don't like this game
I don't like this position also rupee 6
just simply couldn't I ate a 2 is
winning so he can play this justice and
wow if a to 7 so I wasn't sure how to
improve so I decided to go retreat my
chin
and I think it's just still hard to
defend here and I just couldn't find
something here and he played this one in
this I think it is already in winning
foot black but still needs some it's not
easy
well anyway I I managed to like h5 c
five and six rupees Ellen and if
something like this it's night so this
is my idea and he played three four and
now if you shop see why it's so simply
winning and I play this I didn't see
this idea
like if you go real k2 and it's the 93
oh no we just yeah she'll be sorry sir
no this is me so
so I play I think it's winning now and I
like my this move I mean like 87 looking
1 into 2 and I was default so he played
this and I'm glad that I found this move
if take God's just take and capture the
rook so like just why it doesn't have
any plan here
I just go back with my night so and move
my rook and just push it and I a rook
versus two points should be winning and
after this he decide to resign and I'm
going well so far in the Fall Classic I
don't think you've played Shimano before
I was checking databases there's got to
be at least several new players in this
field that you haven't played before
what do you think of the competition so
far in this tournament
oh I think actually everyone is ok this
is a strong tournament for me I mean
everyone is try and I think I mean they
are they just play you know very very
very nice and it's not easy for me to
find any chances to win a game it's not
easy for me just that they play like
very precise in something I wanted to
congratulate you on becoming the
Challenger for the Women's World
Championship next year between now and
then what are you doing in the chess
world to prepare or what events are you
competing I think it's a very special
tournament I think of course it will be
a lot of pressure and
well for me it's a very new experience
I've never played a chan challenge
watch amateur before so well I guess
it's very lucky for me see how good -
now you play it in the knockout World
Championship before I believe but right
this is this is the match do you hold
this in higher regard than the big 64
player knockout I think both of
tournament is not easy because the
knockout see it it's very random and you
you have no idea we will still open and
tomorrow and also there's only two game
everything will be very I mean hard to
know and the the match game it's like
you know your openings already like you
know half or one year so you would do
some prepare and think both of player is
very hard to play all right I mean the
randomness you were talking about look
at the World Cup right now you know it's
watching it I think it's very I have
found some very nice game exciting and
crazy
well the universal rating systems number
3 women in the world fides number 2
woman in the world and the official
world chess challenge err for the
women's title jeu engine thank you for
joining me and congratulations today
let's take a look at the standings in
group a after seven rounds only two left
with the players evenly staggered in the
standings it's still anybody's
tournament and there are several key
games on Wednesday September 13 in the
8th round but the most important at
least mathematically is on board 5 she
Manav vs. jariabek I'm here in Group B
with Grandmaster Alexander Shabalala
who today had a little bit of a birthday
gift I'm not really sure when it
occurred exactly but with the black
pieces he drew what the computer said
was losing for him against
Oxshott Chandra Alex first of all happy
50th birthday thanks a lot I hope you
enjoyed the cupcake I was really glad I
got was able to get that on camera I
almost missed it what about this game
here with AK shot all right
oh well first of all surprisingly on my
birthday I got like absolutely horrible
scores
I mean out of before this game it was
half point out of six throughout the
years you know from the games that I've
played on my birthday there were like a
lot of people who were just given me a
drive but from those that play just have
to point out of six you know about 40
years so another birthday gift today
okay I was not supposed to survive but
the game turned out to be like pretty
interesting so I decided this is about
time to do something on the kingside if
I can and somewhere around here I
started looking at all kind of ideas of
maybe Rudy five work age five or be 55
and the night goes to e6 g5
kind of attack but of course the
computer defense it simply doesn't work
and for a while I shot played really
well so Ruki six I'm trying to
intimidate him into like possible route
g6 group take g3 but of course the young
generation does not believe in this
anymore and so clean before 96 I get it
all the temples I can get but
unfortunately five
Bishop of 1 would be 6 and well you know
I played that for here of course I
understand that it it has a simple
refutation ok
but he really went down to increment at
this point 8 loose or maybe 40 seconds
in his clock and actually after force
sequence takes takes takes takes
he needs to find rocky 3 if he doesn't
play ricky 3 black is winning on the
spot for example looks like Kruk g3 was
the same idea that's before this simply
loses two beautiful shot III to White's
position just disintegrates like
immediately so but you know what can you
do the youngsters the calculating like
computers and after rookie three if any
of my route could go to F file an attack
F to black his winning unfortunately
neither route can move okay the b6
through guards did Brooke yeah this one
has to protect the bishop I simply don't
have time for Jeff six or okay fate and
if I don't have time for that it means
white next moves or Bishop g2 night f1
consolidating and well even if I get two
points for it would not be enough so I
simply try it my last practical chance
here
of d6 neither one is absolutely correct
Andrew G Phi and here's the key moment
of the game were like playing an
increment for last ten Mohs caustic shot
half a point so basically any move other
than kundi to win some wins right there
a Quincy 321 rooks you won not sure
about no can gauge one we need to
protect the point enough - but that's do
you see what I mean it's like anything
but Queen d2 but Queen d2 looks like the
most solid one even if you can though
you can argue maybe Cooney one looks
better for other for many people but he
played Queen d2 and even though computer
still thinks that route after Ruby six
row vg3 a white is better here it's not
true and rook takes you three and
luckily I'm gonna win the pawn on d4 as
well and then it's gonna be two pieces
two pieces for I'm sorry two points for
the piece so this is what happened
Bishop c6 I even had a luxury in this
position to avoid rook against Luke and
Bishop ending of course it's a draw and
I know how to defend it but like I
didn't see the necessity to go into the
Sun game because I can get what I got in
the game which is a rocket knight versus
rook which is like a three wheel draw
against a bishop at least you need to
know some key positions something but no
it's just a draw okay computer might say
plus one whatever it's just trade those
dressers so lucky on my birthday can I
say yeah I think you could say you know
AK shots playing on the increment cost
him half a point it's not the first time
we've heard that Akshat has a problem
with letting his time tick down a little
too much is that a problem you ever had
in your younger days I actually yes when
I was at that age I had this problem it
was pretty horrible it was well we
didn't have increment back then but it
was something for like 20 moose for one
minute pretty much in every game when I
was like 12 years old or something and
it continued its continued to bother me
was and was known problem for me but
nobody could help me before the baretsky
came to rescue surprisingly I was I'm
not technically address key students or
anything but as a member
of the Russian jr. team you know we all
had some time with you know the best
coaches and Marc dress key just during
the I think that was - in 80 81 and 82 -
winter camps of the Russian junior teams
or just two sessions just like come
quickly
just hold that problem for me what's the
secret what's the secret secret is very
busy so when you get into time trouble
by move 20 when you already started
playing an increment in the complicated
position in every game that means only
one thing
it's the problem with decision-making so
your decision-making is not structured
enough and like when you see that the
danger is coming okay is that you
clearly behind the schedule because if
you think about it you only have like
three minutes for moon once you start
the game probably even less right more
or less it's three minutes so if you
think for 10 minutes and then 10 minutes
again
no wonder okay you're gonna be in a ton
trouble and but if you spend in time and
on critical loops it just means your
decision-making yes
Fulton okay you got to do something
you've got to work on it and risky had
designed like a special set of positions
that would
specifically you know address the
problem I'm still I'm extremely grateful
for him to you know help them in that
regard it's like heck for Akshat I think
he should find someone who will help him
exactly the same way I mean there's a
lot of coaches for students of diversity
and I'm pretty sure they get access to
the databases that set of problems that
helped me when I was like so we have the
former US and US Open champion Grand
Master Alexander Shambhala thank you for
joining me and congratulations I guess
on your draw today
all right happy birthday let's take a
look at the standings so shabal of is
functionally out of this tournament but
it's still up for grabs between many
great players one of the top placers
Allen picha of Argentina will take on
Nisha Chun on board two on Wednesday
during the eighth round a very important
game perhaps the most important in Group
B and now we have made it to the final
rounds of the fall chess classic be with
us on Wednesday at 1 p.m. central
be with us for the final day on Thursday
at 11 a.m. Central and if it's necessary
in either field the playoffs later on in
the evening on Thursday September 14
check all the action out on chess 24 and
us chess champs calm